[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 50 of
GameSpot after dark we made it we made a
family minutes episode 15
it took us 50 weeks to get here I'm very
proud that we got here joining me this
week on the 50th episode is Kelly play
hello jean-luc psyche hello and for the
first time ever Edmund Tran hello it's
me
how y'all doing I'm calls it's [ __ ]
freezing in Australia right now it is
[ __ ] hot here I was dying I finally
caved and bought shorts I haven't owned
shorts in forever but I wouldn't bought
shorts because I could not deal with it
but these Magikarp shorts that are like
they're like overalls but when you fold
down the front
it's a Gyarados like a surprise here and
what that's all and it's an Australian
company the company is black milk and
they had the all right yeah one a whole
Pokemon collection that like I like they
sell out like within a minute so I had
to like wishlist everything and then
like be online on time to buy these
Pokemon cool awesome before we get into
today's episode there's a few things I
do want to go over first is that Lucy
and temor not here might be kind of
weird that they're not here for the 50th
episode but they are both on vacation
actually and I didn't really want to bug
them and get them on I'm sure they would
have been cool with it but play for all
is officially unofficially done I guess
you could say and those two put in a lot
of work as everyone on staff but they
they were smart and requested a week off
you know they plan their schedules
essentially so they're off this week but
this works out because we will be
talking about goes to Tsushima because
edy reviewed that we'll get to that
after what we've been playing the other
big thing I want to talk about is that
there are some changes coming to
GameSpot after dark the big thing is
that we aren't going to be doing video
anymore at least for now the idea behind
this is that
things have been really busy and it's
very hard to produce a video podcast
while everyone's located in different
places so we're going to focus on audio
now if you only watch this on YouTube
that's bad news I know it kind of sucks
but you can still find the podcast on
iTunes Spotify Google Play I mean pretty
much anything except SoundCloud because
we only got like three or four listens
on SoundCloud so I killed that one
because it was like $200 a year sounds
like now we did it it's fine those those
twelve people can just transition the
other thing is that we are going to try
to keep with the set cast for the most
part we will still have other people
subbing in and we'll have guests and
whatnot but we're gonna try to keep to a
somewhat familiar cast and we're going
to try to keep the show a little bit
shorter what this means is we're gonna
try to keep it around an hour a little
over an hour if you scroll through the
feed you've probably noticed that we're
kind of getting close to that two-hour
mark and I personally don't really want
to do that because a it creates more
work and B I think the the more succinct
we are the tighter the episodes are
we'll see how that goes I mean we've got
a lot of people who are very passionate
about games here and when they want to
talk about something they really want to
talk about it
so that being said I'm not gonna
purposely cut things out necessarily of
episodes to get it to that length but
we're gonna be try we're gonna be trying
to aim for a shorter length overall and
you know as always if you guys have any
feedback please please please tweet at
us we look at all that stuff we take all
that into consideration or you could
join the GameSpot discord if you DM me
on Twitter or you can email after dark
podcast at GameSpot calm and you can
leave comments in the after-dark Channel
and all that stuff we look at we have a
lot of people working on this podcast a
lot of people who really like this
podcast including you know everyone here
today everyone on staff and we're gonna
make this as good as it can be so with
all that in mind I just want to thank
everyone so much for listening to 50
episodes because it's pretty unreal like
I don't talk too much about this but you
know when I started at GameSpot five
years ago the one thing I wanted to do
is have a podcast I
was just something that I kind of felt
like was missing like we had the lobby
but it was a video podcast and I kind of
had a different vibe so it is one of my
dreams to have this going and have this
going for 50 episodes now and we're
gonna keep going so I just want to thank
everyone for all their support and of
course everyone at GameSpot - who is
also supporting this because it has been
a blast so far and we're excited to keep
it going
good job done Jake yeah there's my
little spiel for today with that said
we're gonna move on to the Chris from
Dayton Ohio segment Callie song there we
go it's like you've got this down 50
episodes in and we've got this down
Edie what else you want to tell us about
yourself
hi I'm ed what do you know how'd you get
started at GameSpot what are what are
you game did I say game stop game stop
stop I don't think it's working the EB
Games which after which I did come into
GameSpot as a video editor like about 12
years ago now and I basically did it was
a video producer for about six or seven
years until I then moved into editorial
now now take care of Australia and I'm
like the the figurehead there but I'm
just a regular editor and on the glass a
dad of Australian that's okay I'm the
dad of Australia old Australia so yeah
yeah I've been around a while not always
a visible bit I have been here so very
long and I'm very tired it also helps
with reviews a lot I just want to
emphasize that Chris Wright Chris
Beaumont who's the head of video is has
been a longer and Randolph Ramsey who's
editor-in-chief has been here a few
years more than that he used to be my
boss back in Australia before he moved
over but yeah I think that's isn't it
my boss is still Randy my boss is
basically always
he's my bus I know yeah yeah yeah he's
cool
yeah all right you guys are all young
and I don't know another part of the
curse from Dayton Ohio segment is like
what kind of games do you typically
gravitate towards and like what's your
like some some of your favorite games
kind of thing um well I play a lot of
things I hate this question cuz I like I
play old games you know it's fun of my
job but ones that I've traditionally
been like super keen on things like
rhythm games I was like really into rock
band 4 and harmonic stuff for like a
long long long long time I've given them
like thousands and thousands of dollars
and I've had this like full on a drum
kit I can see in the background of your
place Kelly yeah I just really love
music and music games and I also really
like fighting games so I play a lot of
those not at a competitive level or
anything but just as a avid fan but
aside from that yeah I'd like to seek as
much like any stuff as I can that you
know I play everything so anything and
everything except the sports that's the
same thing they're gonna learn like all
these other rules and stuff like that
and uh you know they're American sports
too whatever your are there any like
footy games there are they've
alternately been really bad really yeah
I'm like Australian football as well as
like rugby league and like cricket games
they've they've all like being made
they're still being made but they'll all
just always been have always been
mediocre so yeah
God probably when I started they
released their lacrosse game and that's
why Peter found out that Mike played the
cross and made my cravat and Mike might
found himself in the game because it was
College the cross and it was like anyway
really
why so that's what Mike told me maybe it
wasn't actually Mike maybe it was just
the same number on like the same team
because I don't think they had rights to
use anyone's I don't know how worth but
basically what it came down to is like
there was a character that was
Mike and he was like is this like a
conflict of interest but I think he gave
him like a three or something I've never
heard that story holy it was like when I
first started when he first started to I
guess that's me we have a marketing guy
in Australia who was uh like a semi-pro
like like soccer player and he was in
like football manager it likes you could
find his name and recruit him it's
pretty cool yeah sports and that's the
only sports segment we'll ever have and
like Michael comes back on the show
which will probably be soon yeah all
right well then with that said and done
let's move on to what we've been playing
Callie do you want to start then sure
I'm just finished my I'm rewatching
avatar last airbender and I just
finished book one so my voice is doing a
thing I don't know what's going on with
it but um it's very emotional for me I
get like chills that last episode is so
good I love avatar and then um I you
know I still play Animal Crossing every
day and I did this big
I took a I took my new Kazan adventures
to the next level so first I I did
finish my rock circle that was a
two-week project I finally finished it
the mannequins are gone I can decorate
again but my big trading thing is I used
the Kazan to trade for items I need like
I bought the mushroom lamps for my
forest on Macca's on because I don't
want a time travel
the next thing I've been doing is going
on the Nook is on discord and they have
a cataloging channel where you can go to
someone's Island and like pick up the
item so it's in your catalog and you can
order it for yourself later and I want
to catalogue a lot of stuff for like
completion so I went to someone's island
and I catalogued every single item in
every single color for the diner set and
then also every color of the simple
panels and every color of the box sofas
and then I went to another island and I
got the complete rattan set in every
color
what are you gonna do when you've
cataloged everything I I'm also really
trying to I don't want to make all of
the bug and fish models cuz some of them
are like I'm not gonna use them like I'm
gonna use the butterflies for like a
flower butterfly garden thing that's my
plan and then like there's some that I
wanted like the seahorse because I I
thought I'd be cute for like a beachside
mermaid sort of vibe there's some that I
don't want so I'm just trying to
catalogue as many as I can just ha you
can't order them it won't do me any good
it'll just be in my catalogue so if any
listeners have bug in fish models they'd
be willing to let me pick up and then
put back down that's my next project I
got like ten today from somebody and I
got a tarantula model to keep so big day
for me did you play much animal crossing
yeah I went pretty hot in Animal
Crossing for a long time because I was
like on leave when it came out and so I
had a lot of time to sink into it I
think what's a come became back and
started having to play other games I
kind of lost it kind of dropped off it a
little bit I also have like familial
responsibilities so I don't have as much
free time as I used to it's like I need
to like focus but I'd really would like
to get back into Animal Crossing because
it does bring me a lot of peace yeah
last week we were talking about like
some of the our favorite games of the
year so far I was like I just want to
give a special shout out at the Animal
Crossing and I talked a lot about animal
crossing and tomorrow was just like cool
and then we moved on to the next thing I
was like who's like what I let you talk
about Final Fantasy 7 and go off about
it and stuff but I'd say that he was
like cool we're airing out some dirty
laundry here because I wasn't there to
dine out crossings honor I know I know I
tried I tried my best
yeah I I just I love that I have I can
create projects for myself so like
obviously terraforming and decorating
the island is a big one but I also
really like the idea of cataloging
things and I think in the in past Animal
Crossing games you know I didn't really
have the resources to get items that
were harder to get and in this game you
know I can use Nickerson
I can use turnip exchange there's all
sorts because turneth exchange is more
than just earnest like I can get a lot
of items that way so I was really
excited because the the sets that I got
today like the diner set is like six or
seven different colors and you know you
only have one color that's like native
to your island so I would have a really
hard time getting those other ways so
it's just like there's something
satisfying about it I'm just checking it
off and then I go into new Kazan and I
add them to my catalogue I'm very
thorough it is not peaceful for me I'm
very intense it's pretty intense dude
you could like spend so much time just
like you're on the nitty gritty which
you are and that's just a crazy way to
play because when I play I'm just kind
of like I don't wander around like pick
up some food and like maybe checking on
the catalogue it's very chill compared
to what seems you're doing on a daily
basis I'm like oh I gotta move my
hundred flowers that I have here like I
I breathe flowers or I did I have all
the colors now so I don't need to do
that anywhere but like I I have to move
them all to one spot so I can terraform
that spot and then I move them all back
it takes a really long time someone's
gonna do it and your animals don't do
[ __ ] they just walk around you know and
complain about weeds or something like
that and they're not gonna terrify you
seen him break a sweat never seen him
break a sweat they're always working out
it's true in their defense but I don't
think most animals sweat so it's
probably for the best I don't know we
didn't need like NBA 2k 21 at levels
it's like that would work uh Shawn Luke
do you want to tell us what you've been
doing this last week sure uh well I
played destiny on PC which you've been
playing so I don't know if we want to
save that for your second both talked
about it are you Terra
wouldn't take my the other thing first
okay imagines gonna be quick yeah so I
played the new Borderlands DLC huge
bottle of wine if you're just listening
to this podcast please note that he took
out a bear
comically large bottle of wine that was
a normal bottle of wine chamois it
looked very it's actually pretty large
like that's more of a stand stay Metis
arch it's larger than average I'd say
I'd say meeting medium/large anyway
Borderlands anyway Borderlands new DLC
it's terrible it's so bad I'd sews the
part one no its western it's coming down
bounty bounty of blood I think you
should probably get that right if I'm
gonna should talk it a quick question
generally the last DLC was Lovecraftian
inspired and was vaguely racist as
jordan remai yeah
terrible it was outside of that even
less oh yeah so on compared to that is
this better or is it it's weird okay so
me and my girlfriend we've been playing
we played through Borland's one and two
before it came out and she ended up
loving it
I had a really good time we're like ask
like Brian's three me end up pretty
mixed on it you know we're like it's
okay but it's not really hitting the
same highs but we're excited for the
DLCs because I think Borderlands DLCs
are like some of the best of that series
and these have been like pretty
disappointing even by like the lower
standards of Borderlands 3 as a product
like yeah like that that last one the
Lovecraftian one was like not only was
it just like okay you're not really
doing anything interesting with the
Lovecraft and it kind of has it's
ignoring a lot of the racist undertones
of Lovecraft as as Jordans very
excellent article pointed out it also
just wasn't funny at all like it would
just set up a joke and then just not not
have a punchline and it was really bad
so we're playing that that's amazing
yeah great so we're playing the new one
which which is called bounty of blood
and it it's so it's western-themed but
that the town is all Japanese aesthetic
and it's really weird and I don't know
why it it's like that
like I don't know what they're going for
like there's no joke like they don't
make like a joke about it it's just like
here's like a Western and everyone talks
like they're in a Western but all the
towns look like ancient Japan and they
have kanji on the signs and their names
are like like Chad Kasumi like they have
like English first names to Japanese
last names but then they all just look
like white people and it's like its
bafflingly bad it's like so weird like I
I'm like is this racist I don't even
like no like I'm Knology what's up
everyone calls you a tamagotchi like
just like that what's up Tomodachi and
you're like oh my god well I love you
with all my kokoro maybe it's a very
clever play on the mashup between
because you know how like surgery any
films rift on Kurosawa films like okay I
got this full of dollars and a few
dollars moral drift on you Jimbo Sanjaya
it's a very clever it's a very clever
fusion of the two to make some sort of
commentary about a cultural
appropriation so that's what I thought
like my head it was like okay there's a
connection as you pointed out but I was
waiting for them to make like a joke
about it and there's no jokes there's
just there's like a character who's like
um like a Sam Elliot like narrator where
he's like you know they went on down and
there was the guy and they shot him but
like he doesn't make jokes he just he's
plays and it's all weird least rates for
like a Borderlands game like Borderlands
3 like the jokes were terrible but they
were making jokes like Michael and I
there's no jokes
Michael and I actually interviewed the
creative lead for this DLC for the play
for all and he was saying that they
wanted to have less jokes and focus more
on the story
it sounds like it didn't quite work but
I thought that was kind of interesting
when he was telling it work there are no
jokes oh yeah there's no story either
like they're talking about these like
characters and like the sheriff gets
Shawn you're like I don't care about any
of this like Borderlands without its
jokes doesn't have like top quality
writing to like invest you in it like
you need you need like the humor to like
get you interested in it not only
saundra maybe maybe if like the looting
is enough for you like you'll have a
good time with this dlc but late a lot
2000 hours he talked about it oh yeah
he's got some absurd amount of time when
i am i can't imagine that and he was
like yeah i just mute all of the
dialogue and just it's good idea and and
and just like just do it for the looting
and shooting and like dude you could
like play destiny or something well it
sounds like the joke was on you all
along yeah i think i think this is the
first Borderlands dlc i won't finish
like we play this for one night and we
were just like now i have better things
to do with my life replacing wess
stranding yeah like play some destron
ting on pc which is how far you Jake at
far view I'm about to get the first bike
you know the bike that's broken down
outside of what is it a not City I don't
know one of the not cities yeah west
central outpost whatever I'm loving it
personally like it's me because I I
remember liking deaths training early on
when it came to ps4 but I like knew the
end I I was really like I was getting to
the point where was like I can't do this
much longer but for some reason I was so
ready to jump back into this game on PC
and I'm having a lot of fun maybe funs
not the right word but I'm enjoying it
quite a bit it's so meditative and it's
gorgeous on PC it's absolutely stunning
on PC
the vistas in the photo mode is great -
I haven't messed around a whole lot
within especially coming off ghosts
Tsushima it's like yeah I wish there's a
little bit more here but you can make
bebe do little like post you can do like
a little like thumbs up like a Fonzie
pose and like and then you can like
coordinate BB's pose with Norman Reedus
pose and like it sounds like you need to
play around with the photo mode a lot
more I I do need to play I mean I mess
around a little bit but I haven't taken
any photos really I just opened it and
you know mess around with all the
options and whatnot but I am having a
really good time with it I'm excited to
play more I wonder if part of the reason
why I'm enjoying it more is just because
I have more time on my hands because of
all this and like hey I don't know like
this game hits different than it did in
2019 oh my god for sure but I guess I'm
just more patient with it right now and
I think that's pretty much what it comes
down to is that I'm not part of that is
because I had more time part of it is
because I know what to expect so I'm
just taking my time I'm trying to help
out I'm trying to get all the I don't
know settlements to 5 stars as well yeah
which at the time seemed like something
I would never want to do but now that
I'm in this world I'm like yeah I kind
of want to help out all these people
that I can and maybe spend more time
working on roads and building different
things I don't know how I don't know if
I'll finish it because this is a long
game but as of right now I'm I'm really
enjoying it I'm happy I picked it up on
PC and I'm you know I it looks great I
think it's great so far yeah I really
want to get back into it it's like the
first time I played it through it was
for like walkthrough for games but I
rushed through that thing I ended up
really liking it at the end but I was
like man I really want to go back and
just like actually take my time so yeah
I'm gonna be soon
you guys follow sorry you go oh I was
going to say I really want to play it
again I almost gave that game at 10 I
loved it so much and I was elisandra
sent me some videos of like the new
stuff with the head craft and I was just
like it got
my heart I was like I just want to play
this game again I really loved it so but
I don't have a PC with me right now so I
have to wait but I guess I could play to
get on ps4 but then I want to see the
brightness that I'm excited to play it
because I never finished it um not
because I didn't like it but because of
like something about the timing I just
like moved on other stuff but I think
like the because that game is so core to
like playing with other people that it's
like a fresh chance to like replay it on
PC now that everyone else like it so I
really want to finish it this time
yeah one of the communities like on ps4
these days like if there's still stuff I
was curious about that too
cuz it wasn't it kind of a fail it not a
failure but it wasn't a success I guess
you could say I feel like there was
rumors that Sony was displeased at the
sales of that game mmm-hmm I don't know
if they're true but I just remember
seeing rumors that it I don't know it
just didn't sell as much as they'd hoped
anyway you guys promised you guys Mel
alliance McDonald on Twitter he's like
is an Australian who isn't really into
video game hacking and he hacks a lot of
souls games and blood-borne games so
he's been he's been hacking deaf
stranding and the first thing he did at
everyone's request was like try and get
a shot if Norman Reedus his penis and
say what what he still got some work to
do like for the shower scenes and stuff
but what he discovered is that when you
urinate in the game like he hacked the
camera to go in the front he like
normally this has no penis he just like
hold his hands in front of his crotch
and like we just comes out like 30
centimeters that say that's a bit of a
disappointment
so there's only him for those updates I
I just I don't really have a joke here
just want to say Norman's Reedus oh I
should actually a joke I should say that
Michael hiam did update my original dust
training review with his PC impressions
it's more technical folk technically
focused um Lucy expert yeah so that's at
the top of the review I was rereading my
review like cuz I wrote that review
really like at the 11th hour cuz I liked
I'm I'm not great at that part um but I
was reading it and I was like man I love
this game but then I was like I put a
bunch of there's like sub headers in the
review and I haven't done that again
since I was like oh I forgot that I did
this maybe I should do it again why did
I so man wild times I forgot like
everything about that review process
that was a heck of a time Kelly yeah I
wasn't like I did like three
back-to-back reviews yeah that was crazy
I remember that binge anchor like five
start every city in like two days
there's something insane like that yeah
yeah then like he finished it as you
were finished your review oh yeah
we were all in the office late and I
like Ben was finishing the game and I
was like sitting there like writing like
a god the embargo is midnight
fun times I was at home sleeping you
know it happens I am genuinely excited
about mods for that game like I want to
replace like I want people to like
replace all the ABS with like weird
stuff like yes like a ride with Norman
Reedus like whatever like weird things
could you replace that with like days
gone advertisement yeah or like instead
of like the motorcycle reving when he's
like taking a dump like it I don't know
some big scoop sounds yeah I I really
because the like the monster energy
drink was replaced by like respecting
women juice you know something I also I
never finished the pizza quest and I
want to go back and do that oh I didn't
finish but do you remember if you
finished the beer quest your monster
energy gets replace with beer yes time
fall beer they were like we found a way
to make which which I thought was like a
such a neat detail how they like found a
way to make beer better and quicker
because of time I want somebody to this
is such random I want somebody to
replace the character name for Jeff
Keeley's character I don't remember what
it was I just want them to replace it
with actually Jeff Koons
Luda this fan I want him to actually be
called Jeff Keely in the game I think
it'd be funny I don't know why
well anyway should we talk about the
game that people want us to talk about
yeah are you being so cryptic the game
that Edward I don't know
yeah I'm gonna know numb right go ahead
you reviewed it gave it gave it a 7 out
of 10 what are your thoughts overall
good game it's good game pretty good
game alright listen your questions what
7 means yeah this game is it's it's weak
I definitely went up on a it's
definitely roller coaster you go if
hiding you have lows and they're
definitely a lot of low points but
overall it is a very pretty and
compulsive open-world game with some
pretty I thought was pretty good combat
Jake and I think I you hated it right
well okay yeah I think it's really good
like a really I mean to summarize stuff
and I think this really captures a lot
of that pretty well and you know by the
end of it you'll basically just like
brimming around like a really really
pretty world and like getting to sword
fights and just like like doing like
checklist all open-world things which
for a lot of people including myself
like really massage is that part of your
brain that lets you I don't know it's a
very relaxing loop of things to do know
at the mall game at the same time it
does fall back on a lot of I guess
tropes and structures that have really
old open-world games like it feels like
an old Assassin's Creed like before
Odyssey in origins it's just like a lot
of question marks in the map a lot of go
to this place and do is do a little side
activity and check it off and get a
little reward and the quests are kind of
really boring in that sense too because
it's a lot of walk with a dude to have a
chat look at the thing hit a button get
into a fight and then get a reward which
you know isn't really interesting and
early on and I think I feel like I've
seen a lot of people feel the same way
about this early on that really really
drags you down because you're just doing
a lot of that all at once but once you
start to get past there and you start
getting more tools and the world opens
up a bit more you can kind of leave that
behind a little bit more and so enjoy
the world what it is which is an
exploration game that lets you kind of
you know there's no like mini map and
stuff so you kind of just go where your
fancy takes you and I feel like that
that feeling of exploring the world and
it's almost breath of the wild ish like
definitely not to the stand the breath
of the world but it it lets you just
like act upon your curiosity and find
something cool to do so yeah overall I
liked it but it definitely has its its
flaws yeah anyone else play it no I
played oh just me I I didn't hate it by
any stretch like I I think it's a good
game I agree with you know in a lot of
ways I just didn't I just wasn't having
fun like I really liked the exploration
I liked seeing the world I thought the
world was gorgeous the photo mode in
particular I spent so much time messing
about the photo mode getting shots cuz
it it's the best photon what I've ever
seen in a game like there's some options
that I wish were there like I wish I
could make Jin disappeared turn them off
so I can just get them but apart from
that like the photo mode is top-notch
it's so good yeah it's wild that it's
like the first game I've seen where the
photo mode is actually like a thing on
your UI
like it's gone by default and it's like
an actual thing that you can trigger
like they want you to use it you know of
course because the game looks so damn
good that you'll want to be yeah yeah oh
you'll want to be like taking photos and
the animated still thing is really cool
too so even though you freeze the world
wind and like particles and stuff still
happen and it just looks [ __ ] good
yeah that was my favorite thing like the
animated stuff because you could make
shots look really cinematic like happy
yeah like the slow pans like I remember
doing them in like uncharted and stuff
and you do slow pans but the world would
still be frozen but with that you can do
these slow pans or push ins and you can
add what do they call it in the game you
can add like clutter I guess and you can
make like a bunch of fireflies spawn
yeah
and appear just like a thousand
butterfly
20 to 100 percent it is ridiculous it is
like this doesn't make any sense but and
like even when I turned it down to like
10 percent I'm like there's still two
minutes let's get a day that's a lot but
I automotives great but like the the
combat and like the mission structure I
just found like those two together I
just couldn't do it because like no luck
on like I get why there's no lock on I
think if there was a lock on that was
probably that probably would have been
an issue and you'd have to imagine you
know a triple a game in 2020 a
third-person action triple a game
they're probably experimenting with lock
on without lock on they probably found
out that no lock on is best but I just
did not like the lock on this combat
because I'd end up attacking people I
didn't want to attack or dogs in
particular I found incredibly annoying a
fight and like I'd use your throwing
abilities and sometimes I hit the wrong
enemy and that would mess me up
just the combat was not doing it for me
at all and I think maybe part of it is
because I played the [ __ ] out of Secura
and that is like yeah third-person
action combat for me and I know the
games are very different but even the
settings like though there's Japan the
settings are still very different but
for some reason I guess I just went in
expecting more that like like lethality
and like I don't know the weight that
second row had that this kind of just I
don't get there I can submit the hair
like I feel like the way they designed
like a damage output of a sword and the
hits you could take like it feels really
good in the animations like make it feel
really chunky but yeah I think I I had
some issues with the lock lack of
lock-on to begin with and I think the
comment system definitely wants you to
play a certain way like it's not a
comment system where you can be too
aggressive when you're finding a lot it
may like a it's gonna because that one
just blocks all the time right I think
it's a it's a it's a combat system that
wants you to be more reactive so you
kind of just what a mimic like those
samurai fights that you might see in
like samurai movies where you just are
standing still someone makes a move and
you like to flicked it and then you take
that chance and start like steamrolling
them as you
so by the end of the game where you have
a lot of abilities and stuff and you
start becoming the ghost of Tsushima you
know as soon as you power you dude and
you cut him down like everyone starts
like breaking their guard because
they're like oh [ __ ] and then you you
can use those openings to start doing
cool things like throwing your kunai
like throwing grenades at people doing
weird things like kicking them in the
air and like shooting them down with the
bar but yeah you need you do need to
wait for those openings so you want to
be able to stay there like see what's
happening around you and then be able to
react in every direction and I think
that's kind of what they were going for
a bit it still is a little weird in some
instances so yeah yeah okay I do I do
want to play more because like
especially watching like max did a
combat montage showing off how cool the
combat can be and like okay that looks
really cool
so I I do I'm aware that I do probably
need to play more and learn these
different abilities but man like it's
the fact that I don't really like the
combat the the mission structure I think
is right like there's a tailing there's
an instant fail tailing mission yeah
there's a lot of those well I've only
played one of you and I was like are you
kidding me are we really doing this
which which which I found frustrating
and then I the story has not grabbed me
at all I've heard it gets better after
act 1 and I just finished act 1 I don't
wanna say too much about what's
happening but I just like move to the
next area I guess you could say yeah I
don't know if things get more
interesting but as of right now like I
am NOT invested in a single one of the
characters except Yuna I think you know
it's kind of cool dude is pretty cool I
think yeah to your point act in act 2 it
really opens up that the story gets a
bit more interesting
there's alot more gameplay stuff that
starts to come in and yeah you do it
does feel a lot less hand holy than that
first act yeah which is you know it's
not a great start but it does get better
and I think you know buddy by the end of
it you know you don't have to deal with
a lot of that [ __ ] and then you you
and that's where you get to the point
where you just do want to explore by
yourself and do the whole side stuff and
so you know finish clearing the map so
to speak like you know I want to go back
and play right now and that's the
feeling that leaves you
but you can't you know I can't just
forget all those there was hours where
they were just leading me through like
you know very linear quests in like
instant PAL sales missions and like kind
of stuff something so it's something
that I did want you to talk about a
little bit is one thing you talked about
in the review was how like in some ways
the presentation hits the highs of what
its young to emulate but in other ways
it doesn't and I thought that was super
interesting like what we're I don't know
I guess some examples of how it hit
those highs and then examples of how it
didn't quite get there yeah well I mean
the whole deal with this game is that
it's trying to ape like samurais cinema
and like some of the witch you know some
of these samurais films I've considered
the greatest films of all time in terms
of cinematography and like framing and
that kind of stuff so it's trying to
emulate a lot of that by like having the
beautiful environment you know and
framing that environment in really
beautiful ways and doing really nice
panning shots and playing with depth of
field and all this kind of really cool
stuff that makes it that makes it like
very memorable like it's an incredible
looking game but on the other hand you
know when you're doing a lot of these
it's full of quests there are so many
side quests and you know on top of them
being quite linear they are also pretty
boring to watch so you know in a lot of
open-world games you go to a quest gear
if you have a conversation giving
context about what's happening you know
what you're gonna do like where you got
to kill these people whatever and a lot
of those conversations are they're
boring in the way they're boring because
the characters just don't move right the
acting's good acting is fine the
Japanese voice acting is really good but
a lot of the time you are just watching
two Talking Heads flip back and forth
back and forth back and forth and that
that's common and like that's fine but
when you compare to how how how much
effort they've taken to make this game
look so beautiful and like evoke you
know a sense of passion in you like this
really brings it down and I obviously
took more game and like animating like
characters to move and do like loss of
us to style you know conversations with
like body
or like even GTA style you know in GTA
the character very expressive like
always moving through the environment
there like you know it feels actually
feels like you're watching a movie here
a bit here when you go into a sidequest
that's when the whole movie thing kind
of disappears and you just I don't know
just listening to two people talk about
the something that you know isn't all
that exciting I mean I feel like story
part of this game is serviceable but
it's nothing to write home about it's
just it's just a funnel for you to go
and do something and kill someone so
yeah like you will spend a lot of time
getting into these quests and just
feeling a little bit bored I would say
the only thing that saves it is like you
know even though there are two still
talking heads like if they they often
frame them in the environment quite
nicely so it's like two figures standing
under a giant tree while like petals
rain down and all that kind of stuff and
you know that stuff looks pretty but at
the end of the day you are watching two
mannequins like Yap at each other for
like two to three minutes at the
beginning and end of each quest and then
it that is kind of the downer I mean
that's the those were the points in the
game where I was like getting a little
sleepy I was like you know it's like
men's watches you like ten more quests
after this yeah but once you like I said
once you stop moving away from that
stuff and enjoying the world it gets a
lot better yeah I mean I I loved
exploring like what I explored I thought
was great like I had a lot of fun just
how natural it feels like it's like oh
you're going one way and then a fox
shows up and follow the Fox and then
follow the bird and then I mean there's
like a mom with territory that's been
taken over and you like cleared out and
stuff like that like I did really enjoy
that aspect of it but I just felt like
like the minute I'd get into combat I do
like here we go like I just wish I could
make these enemies disappear and I can
go on my merry way rather than I did
like to stand off stuff though or you
can like yeah wait like that that's
super flashy and cool I thought yeah
once you get more schools like I mean
guys the whole plot of the game is like
gin is like a Bible by the book samurai
and like having to go through these
combat motions but he very very quickly
it's like oh wait ninja [ __ ] is like way
cooler and more effective so once you
start getting more tools as you move on
you just roll up into an enemy card like
throw smoke bomb in there and just go in
and stab everyone in the net so that
might help you out in the few ways yeah
I think the guiding wind stuff which is
the whole know map this is how you get
to an objective thing is really
effective and it really aids that style
of like check box open wolves
exploration because it doesn't there's
no like mini-map like full of icons for
you to constantly be distracted by you
can just kind of move through the world
and if you see something like you can
get distracted by it and you're like
okay I'll do this now rather than
looking at a map and being like oh I
could do this but this one's a little
bit closer but over there and you know
all that kind of stuff yeah so yes
jean-luc you played this game on
kurasawa mode which is black and white
yeah in Japanese what was that like how
is that uh I quite liked it I I'm
finished the game and I'm wondering if I
should maybe turn it back on or turn it
off neither either near the end or after
I beat it because like I mean the game
is like beautiful with all these like
saturated colors and you don't get any
of that obviously because it's in black
and white but I think it I personally
for me I felt like it gave it a really
unique flavor like I think there's
something to be said about like you know
as I pointed out it's trying to capture
the spirit of like you know these
samurais cinema movies and even though
it's like it's something as simple as
just like we'll put it in a black and
white and we'll add like a little grainy
filter and the audio gets slightly kind
of like lo-fi kind of gets crunched down
a little bit it really does like put you
in that mood for those kinds of like
that kind of like movie and that kind of
like experience that I just found myself
like really engaged in it because of
that and I think that's
iiiiii I think I agree with like I
probably more on edge where I'm enjoying
it more than you but I definitely agree
with a lot of the issues of it but I
think like just the the the vibes of the
game are like what carries me through
a lot of it I mean like I think it looks
beautiful
in that like black and white mode like
some of the some of the contrasts like
look absolutely stunning I've there are
a couple issues the game has a few
quests were asks you to find blue
flowers and I have got to bet there's a
few of those I actually haven't gotten
to that yet and everyone in the slack
was like yeah what happens when you play
that curse Salamone I was like oh [ __ ] I
should find out it turns out it doesn't
do anything and so you just straight up
are like blue flowers okay
those look like they slightly stand out
and and I like honestly like kinda
winged it I almost did get lost but then
it it turned out like I don't know what
it's not too demanding we're like I was
able to actually like figure it out
without cheating but that's definitely a
thing they like didn't consider when
they when they did the game and I and I
certainly understand people like wanting
new experience like the vast color that
this game has it's it's interesting
cursor mode because the game is really
vibrant and beautiful and I was reading
about Kurosawa's work in black and white
and one of the things that that the team
would do is like he understood how the
contrast would work in black and white
so they had like camellia flowers and
they actually painted the flowers to
enhance the contrast between the leaves
and the flowers and that's like the
attention to detail that went into the
black and white work and then of course
Kurosawa has also done stuff using color
and in red was really important color so
um it's interesting because I think like
the the movie nosov it like like
crunching up the audio making it a
little grainy ER works but I'm curious
what the process was like getting that
black and white contrast to work
especially when it seems like so much
effort was put into the color meet
cuz because I would say it there are
definitely spots where it feels like it
doesn't work but there are spots where
it feels like it totally works
especially um playing it in HDR we're
like those whites and the blacks like
really pop out with black and white it's
like genuinely like stunning at times so
you're like oh my god this looks amazing
and there's a part of me that like wants
a game that like fully embraces that and
like from the get-go is just in black
and white
yeah it's gota sign that way it's called
mad wolf yeah it's a good game but like
I guess more specifically a game like
this where it's like they're really like
trying to capture the spirit of black
and white film where like mad world was
more like black-and-white comic book art
style hmm yeah I don't know it's it's
like I would personally recommend it but
I have I have seen some people like say
like oh you shouldn't play it because I
like the color stuff and how like
sometimes the the contrast like doesn't
quite work and I can't necessarily
disagree with that but at least for me
I'm also like a weird nerd who like I
played all of le noir in black and white
like like a loser I love that [ __ ]
that's a good game a great team to
playing black and white but I really do
think it's just like games like it gives
off this particular vibe that I just
absolutely love like and that was really
what was carrying me through this game
there's like I somebody who like loves
Japanese cinema and you know like it
like from the get-go I was just like
yeah this is like what I wanted and then
you know as I pointed out I totally
agree like the stilted acting is like a
huge probably like the biggest downside
for me because it's very like okay this
is a video game we have to have two
characters stand here and yeah you know
and that also like it's people have been
talking about this but you know if a
sucker punch to like really focus on
like a ping semi cinema and have the
Kouros r-mo to be like authentic and
then have things like the Japanese
lip-syncing the Japanese voice oh my god
yeah mouth movements of the characters
and
they don't express themselves like
Japanese people because Japanese people
you know when you watch those movies
they're like very boisterous you know
and like they and you can hear that in
the voice acting but that doesn't come
through at all and so total yeah in that
way it's just like okay this is actually
just a Western open-world game you can
tell the mocap actors were English or
alien or at least directed by an English
like talent like theirs it doesn't feel
Japanese that way especially because
like the the main character Jin is like
so clearly influenced by like Sochi her
I'm a foon a butt like doesn't have any
of that same energy
yeah the energy in the Japanese
voiceover is pretty good the energy is
good in the voice and for sure but it's
a weird reversal of like we're used to
watching Japanese stuff with it's like
if you watch it in English you're used
to mismatched mouth movements but not
the reverse we're like the English is
the correct matching and then the other
thing I was I was reading some stuff
about Japanese like people in Japan
reviewing this game and one of the
things was the speech is apparently too
fast for the period yeah there's not a
lot of pauses and then the other issue
is that there's inclusion of like
sarcasm or irony that is really just
very Western I found that really
interesting cuz it seems like the first
wave of Japanese reviewers really liked
the game and liked the portrayal of the
the time period um but I find those
linguistic things really interesting and
of course you know a Japanese person in
Japan their opinions gonna be different
from a Japanese Americans for example so
there's a lot to type into you there but
the just they're like when I read that
there was like sarcasm I was like that's
like the first thing they tell you to
Japanese classes there's no sarcasm and
slang for sure I mean you can you can
tell it's like it's because it's not
just you're trying to capture like the
certain period of Japan but you're also
trying to capture the certain period of
filmmaking yeah like you know that like
1940 was like 50s filmmaking and it's
like the way they acted and the way they
shot things were so different and like
even like
Americans adapting like 50s American
stuff gets wrong the idea that I'm gonna
get it right when it's like a completely
different culture is like yeah I wonder
if that was more like a Sony decision
this is just speculation but I wonder if
it was more Sony being like hey we're
gonna write this for like the
lip-synching for example we're gonna
have American voice actors and have
their lip sync with that the Japanese
would be over I wonder if that was like
a Sony decision of them being like hey
you know this game is going to sell a
lot more in the United States probably
than anywhere else or in North America
and I wonder if that was kind of part of
the decision like you'd have to imagine
like I don't know these people that
sucker punch have probably watched these
movies a ton probably have a very good
idea of what they want to emulate but I
wonder if it just came down to it and
Sony's like yeah you know what like yeah
if we're gonna make it triple a
blockbuster game for North America we
kind of got to make it with English
voice acting in English voice you know
in mind yeah it's the final global
blockbuster for the PlayStation 4 right
it's gonna appeal to as many people as
possible I mean that's that's that's
that's why they prioritize the English
and that's why they like have the themes
of the story like pretty Universal like
it's just about like family issues and
like I'm disappointing my dad and like
what can I do but I want to get out on
my own and do my own thing and all that
kind of stuff but whereas like the
Japanese samurai films like I'm more a
lot more introspective but how do you do
an introspective kind of story in a
open-world action game right it's not
Rashomon that's for sure but I know that
they they did work closely with Japanese
consultants on the game so there was a
lot of Japanese like input I know like
one of the things that was brought up
was like the kanji being Ron or
something and then Japanese people were
like actually it's fine and like I
really haven't I didn't read a whole lot
about that I know it was kind of an
issue at some point is that about the
menu you're talking about yeah the menu
but like I know that they had they had
they worked with actual Japanese people
on the game so there's that too yeah I
feel like they did
a lot of they did at least some due
diligence like and I feel like that
comes through now in certain ways that
yeah I guess when it comes down to it it
has to
it's a appeal to a general audience
mm-hmm well it was just like the
opposite of the last of us any closing
remarks on this good beautiful game yeah
it's pretty pretty yeah I mean I
definitely if you like up all games you
should definitely check it out I mean
it's very comfortable game to play modes
yeah if you like photo modes [ __ ] this
game is yeah for you it's an open world
ass open world game with a very cool
style very much sir yeah but you know I
I do look forward to the day because you
know days gone was kind of formulaic in
this open ball formula as well I feel
but I look forward to the day where the
developers who are currently working on
airport games have actually taken
lessons learned from like things like
breath of the wild and and learn how to
adapt that to you games and see where
they take those new ideas because I
think well I think we're done with this
formula please yeah yeah alright moving
on to listener questions if you've got
any questions for us you can email at
after dark podcast at GameSpot calm or
you can join our discord by DMing me
it's the second time I've said that this
episode but the discord community is
great we'd love to have you there so
make sure to join you can also ask
questions directly in that server anyway
the first one is from fogey bear Callie
do you want to read this one this is a
review question sure didn't think this
would be the right place for this but
when you receive games for review are
they typically the final product or is
it done enough to where it is playable
but there are still some bugs and minor
issues I remember some games having day
when patches and from some of the ghosts
of Tsushima reviews looks like they
could potentially patch some of those
awkward bits that might be too much
inside baseball but I'm curious again
that's from foggy bear I can answer this
I think largely we are getting the final
products like I especially in recent
years I
Sam you're getting like a like a broken
version of the game but there are
definitely cases where there are some
last-minute patches and we typically get
that information ahead of time so the
the PR person will say like there's this
patch scheduled it's going to fix these
issues and then that is really an honor
system thing for us where if we do
encounter a bug like that I mean I I'm
generally of the mind that like I really
don't weigh bugs at all in in my reviews
because you can fix bugs you can't fix
so you can't really patch out structural
problems with a game or narrative
problems that easily but bugs you know
are forgivable to me and I encourage our
reviewers to pay attention to what those
patches aim to fix if they are
encountering those issues and the issues
are relatively minor and don't really
interfere with the experience but yeah
we are getting those pre patch versions
for sure yeah one one interesting thing
is that I mean ed might actually be able
to speak more on this but in the five
years I've been at GameSpot we've
received like either code or like or
like a physical copy of the game we
don't get anything early but there was a
couple instances where we've actually
gotten like debug code which is like
when the game isn't it's like it can be
complete but it's not complete in a
weird sort of way that happened with
tales of force area I think the Tales
games Doody bugs but I reviewed Tales
him symphonia like the remaster and I
had to get a debug console for that yeah
I had to I remember carrying around a
debug ps4 and we got it like months
before the game came out like have a sec
like I think I decided like after two
months of having it Peter was like hey
maybe you should review it and I was
like yeah okay and then I stood like
another month to like finish the game
review it which is is kind of wild like
they just sent it like Justin had it on
a flash drive feels like I got tales of
course area right here we need to debug
the game never happens yeah in there in
the ps3 and 360 days that used to be
like basically common practice where you
would just get like a good CD like sent
in the mail it's like this is the game
play in the office we have I'm in charge
of like the library and so I have like
all of like our old junk
we have on remember the OG xbox 360 with
like those really awkward hard drives
that you would like slot into the top
yeah we have a box filled with them and
they're all like debug review copy of
Saints Row 3 debug like this and this
like they're just filled with them and
I'm like what I don't even what to do
with them like I'm like can we throw
these away like I don't even know the
logistics of it but imagine getting sent
like a giant like brick mail when I was
a freelancer I had to physically go into
the IGN office and pick up a debug ps3 -
review and I'm pretty sure it was Tales
of Symphonia and that is just like not
really a thing anymore sometimes you'll
still get a CD or a flash drive of a
build but like - like now it really is
like we get codes mostly and the codes
are just they activate a retail copy of
the game in some instances we get
pre-release copies and then we get a
second code that activates the retail
version of the game but the saves
transfer in very rare cases the saves
don't transfer which is a pain in the
ass that happened to something recently
Mario Mario maker - I think yeah where I
put 40 hours game and then I think I
knew wouldn't transfer but I was like
we'll see maybe things will change and
you know I ended up putting 40 hours in
the retail version - I think yeah you
still for a lot of like similar
publishers for like PC games and stuff
you still get excuse me you still get
things like Steam preview builds that ok
let's say ok this is the branch that's
gonna be the full game and then you are
basically still playing a preview code
but I think for the most part like all
the major publishers and stuff you'll
basically get final code and in the case
of Ghost of Tsushima they like patch the
game like 4 times and it still isn't out
yet you know so you are still getting
updates like as you are reviewing it and
like they weren't anything that big I
think there was like some HUD changes
possibly but like you don't really
notice they're not like patching in like
oh here's some side quests that we
needed to add to it like usually it's
again it's all feature complete usually
those patches for the most part like I
guess last
kind of weird because I guess the photo
mode wasn't complete or something like
that and they like pashtun photos in
beta yeah something like that so but
like you know the games are usually the
games there's usually like yeah then
that's it yeah yeah featured who played
is a good way to put it like there
there's never really case we're gonna
get a game and like there's part of the
game not included in the code that we
got the patches are normally going to be
things like bugs or UI or something or
the biggest challenge is when one of the
features of a game is an online
component that won't be live until
launch that's when the game is not
feature complete at all and for that we
have reviews in progress but um yeah I
am so glad dee bugs are not a thing
anymore meat you don't have this would
make reading from home much more
difficult great but it was nice back in
the day when you get when you do like
preview previews of Gabey just get like
a like a creepy build on a disk and you
played over and over again rather than
just go to an event and play a game for
two hours and then write about it you
would just have the demo on hand that
was fun
I feel like cyberpunk should do that
cyberpunk should definitely do they
would definitely will never do that I
could use probably about 12 more hours
with that build that I played maybe more
40 can you imagine how much money that
would go for on eBay
and can you imagine all of the youtubers
who would just spoil data-mine all that
[ __ ] would being out there right away no
it's the internet ruined everything is
actually this is like kind of related
below off-topic it's like how with us
being at home we've started to see more
like preview builds that are like remote
we're like you played though is not how
you played cyberpunk you played it like
over like Nvidia now or something like I
played over in video now it actually
went to a place to play it though
oh yes julius internet yeah and it is so
poor that we've still been doing like
physical local demo so i did one for
cyberpunk
and i did one for watchdogs Legion and
Assassin's Creed Valhalla and yeah but
they still like scaled it down to like
the the 1080p stream build to be like
this is the experience that every
gonna get alright so I'm like playing
like a 1080p game blowing up on like a
4k TV just like sitting this close to it
yeah well it still it's local which is
good right let's move on so this last is
not really a question but Jacob McCourt
has been keeping a spreadsheet of
gamespot after dark like I don't know
keeping track of who's on the episode
how long the episodes are blah blah blah
so he's got all these questions for us
to go through and see if we can get
right
the answers are blacked out so I guess
we can go through it and just you know
see what everyone thinks and I can
unhide them okay I love it can I be the
quiz master I'll also guess cuz I can't
see the answers but I I love this okay
do you be the quiz master okay
so here's a little intro here I built a
fun little quiz to celebrate the 50th
episode fun for the community maybe some
cool facts for the show too and having
looked at the questions not the answer
is obviously the facts are very cool umm
alright ready how many hours of podcasts
are in the feed 88 uh 90 episodes a
couple spoiler casts those get pretty
long
it's like 55 I'm gonna say a hundred and
two eighty two point 84 Wow point I was
the closest right
yeah well lower show that's one point
for Jake how many episodes are actually
in the feed okay
I should know this because 60 okay wait
you're the one who populates it okay
yeah 58 mm-hm
he spoiler cast have we done uh I'm just
going with my gut for all of these and
then it's 53 I think it's 53 I can only
think of three spoiler cast so I'm also
gonna say 53 all right what what is it
53 as of joy
so so jean-luc your thinking was wrong
though because this episode episode 50
is not on yet the reason it's 53 is
because intro episode that's like a
minute where I just say so you're still
right we're both right your thinking was
you didn't show your work properly
jean-luc if I was a teacher I got I
don't care if I was a math teacher I'd
only give you partial credit oh my
goodness what's the average length of an
episode hour in 20 minutes hour and 30
minutes
uh-uh 125 to 135 oh you're the closest
93 minutes mm-hmm right wait I said 130
are we doing rounding down or rounding
up I don't know you you can decide
amongst yourselves who gets that I mean
just think you're the closest
numerically closest yeah so John Luke
gets that one how many different
personalities have been on the show
we've had a lot of guests that's gonna
be hard yeah a lot of guests Jesus 50 45
Ed's at a disadvantage here because this
is the first episode you say 30 35 26
and the answer is 44 Joel oh wow that's
all I was cooked I said 35
I said 35 what did I say 45 I think I
said 45 well then we will be tied if
that was the case um okay so we can both
we can we can share that point I guess
or you can keep it I don't know if I'm
not keeping scores I'm not I'm not
keeping I think next time if we do this
again we'll need to have like Jacob
McCourt on here and he can keep track of
things
yeah well Jacob McCourt will be
listening so Jacob
know who wins that's been actually you
know what we've got listeners they can
keep track for which games doing the
work which game spotters have been on
the most shows top three Oh Ellie and
Lucy yeah yeah I was gonna say it's Jake
Ali and Lucy how's it it's gotta be yeah
you guys throwing almost every episode
oh that's okay yeah I guess that has to
be it then anyone is I it says are we
done oh he's even got easy we got the
list Jake 45 calories three seven and
Lucy 32 yeah Wow I'm sorry taking up so
much space
who is the only two-time non gamespot
gasses blessing it's a blessing to
recently all right yeah yeah we talked
about it - I was like you know let's go
how many people have hosted at least one
episode I posted one Jake's hosted
obviously Lucy's hosted timorous hosted
two more hisses who hosted um the
episode with like Alessandro and
Georgian tomorrow tomorrow I don't
remember hosting one but okay so we're
saying for I'm saying for all right the
answers actually five Jake cally tam
Lucy and John Luke I did host one Wow
okay cool
been an early one my stove I don't
remember that at all it was just when we
talked the most Andy that's all how many
how many episodes have been 69 minutes
three one actually see one as well and I
say to say one I'm gonna say one how
many episodes have been hosted from home
including bonus content oh shoot this
weekly right oh my god so we've been
remote since
March um I want to say the first episode
that we did remote was episode 38 so
like 22 21 because it doesn't include
this but then we've had to spoiler
killer cats one for last of us and one
for final fantasy would be 20 24 23 I
can't through math 20 30 sounds right 20
as of July 11th it was wrong i won
oh nice
when was the curse from Dayton Ohio
segment created and who created the
jingle I know there's more created the
jhamora 300% episode early right yeah it
was like four or five I'll say four or
five I'll say five it was episode five
so five tomorrow complete guess how many
cbsi friends have been on the show so
I'm assuming that's like um so we've had
including Jan de Beauvoir Bakalar it
might be it
I can't think of anyone well hold on
would we count chastity cuz universe
Bakalar Jan I think that's it I can't
think of anything that's everybody oh
we're correct cool how many non gamespot
guests have been on the show oh I know I
did so many I say ten I'm just throwing
an eyebrow
well I said 10 I'm gonna say 14 all
right and the answer is oh well of
individuals is that what I said times
Lisa twelve yeah since well yeah what's
the average number of characters and
episode titles no my god numbers or the
word bonus
soft double number is 40 say it wouldn't
twenty-three
it would be much longer on YouTube
because the titles are longer in YouTube
oh [ __ ] yeah we counting but I think
it's just podcast feed I'm pretty sure
it's just podcast feed okay we get
weirder with the podcast feed titles oh
yeah because we know you suckers will
listen to it I'm gonna say 35
I fed sang average is 40 sweet spot
sports the optimal is 40 okay yeah I'll
say procedure 23 I said 23 so I'll move
to try oh no ok it is 30 point 2 mmm yes
what's the longest show oh god I I want
to know that all about whether spoiler
casts a screencast wasn't that long I
don't think we've been very I think like
2 hours and 10 minutes I think is
probably the longest sounds about right
yeah and it was a while ago I was like
one of the early episodes I think um 137
minutes
episode 18 so that's 2 hours and 17
minutes ok those practicals yeah what's
the shortest show I think our first step
will not including like the intro which
was like a minute and a half I think the
shortest one was the first one we did
which is like 49 minutes or something
like that or 47 minutes yeah we've had
some that are under an hour
mmm I when I'm on them well I'm on that
I have no sense of how long they say
it's going 15 minutes 15 50 50 50 okay
okay uh also like I genuinely don't know
I'm I'm thinking if I mean the spoiler
casts were like shorter like like
thought fast he was like an hour or
something we're gonna say 55 I'm gonna
say 45 I'm 47 I'm gonna say 45 Oh 45
contrived spoiler chat oh yeah think
about that that's amazing
um and then finally what episode did the
unofficial catchphrase of the show get
created he's referring to chill hype
vibes I was I glad to be on no I don't
think Michael was Morgan came up with
that Michael well no it was so it was
someone wrote in like loving the chill
hype vibes the dark episode 20 I say 22
it was definitely when we were in the
office yeah I I really have no clue what
do I still think about the email that
called us we abou MERS and I have it
stop singing about I'll say
27:23
what I say 22 you said trying to well oh
that was awesome honestly kind of like
touching to see all of that data about
our show get like it's touching that you
went to the effort to gather that so
thank you Jay Cooke
oh my god yeah thank you you know he's
he's what is his nickname
good good Jacob or pure Jacob something
like that I mean you're even Jake and
you're the bad guy
yeah I'm the bad Jacob he's the good
Jake if I forget this Lucy came up with
it I don't remember i weeaboo MERS
that's all I can aimed her anime slack
channel weeaboo MERS because of that
email well anyway this has been episode
50 of GameSpot after dark thank you all
so much for listening thank you for
sticking with us too episode 50 here's
250 more hopefully even more than that
we're gonna keep going as long as you
guys keep listening so thank you truly
so much for that the support means the
world and thank you guys my cast who's
here right now and the folks who aren't
here but have regularly been on and the
people who just helped support this show
and whatnot but anyway Kali where can
people find you and what are you working
on this week well you can find me on
twitter at inky doji co i NK why do ji k
k oh i am still doing animal crossing
guides Chloe rad and I have
doing a lot around the latest updates
and we're going to do more for the
update coming in August so I'm really
looking forward to that I have no idea
what it'll contain and we're also
working on a big database of all the
villagers which I am transcribing by
hand from the official guide so please
look at that
it hurts my hands there's like 300 of
them I'm only I've only gotten to like
cows like no I just finished dear the
last one I did was dears I have a lot
like 500 right I have a lot more animals
to go so when that goes up please
support and you know as always lots of
reviews on games but you can read read
well we'll probably shout this out but
redeads
go sushi my review obviously a lot of
our reviews are also on YouTube as video
reviews you know we put up a lot of
reviews so this week Paper Mario
something and Paper Mario the origami
King eight out of ten honestly I'm
excited I was like they announced it
like two weeks ago it seems like it his
review actually made me really excited
to play the origami King so definitely
check that out to UM friend of the show
to being a part of min/max
so John Luke you can find me at John
wick psyche I don't have a blue
checkmark so you can still see all my
excellent tweets every day
yeah I got a couple cool things
Callie earlier in the episode you
mentioned Michael doing a what is it
like a not review but like an update
talking about death stranding the good
three paragraph update to the review
yeah yeah so we kind of like a video
version I wouldn't call it a video
review but it's just sort of like
Michaels thoughts on the version in
video form so look forward to that that
should be up hopefully by the time this
is up and then also either at the time
this is up or shortly after should be a
DES training potato mode that mean Ben
have done we ruined that game quite
considerably in some
weird ways so look forward to that and
find you yeah you can find me at Edmund
Tran but I went between for a while I
guess you can speak this privacy oh
really
okay okay sweet but yeah like rate might
go so Tsushima review over on GameSpot
and watch the video with my stupid voice
as edited by Evan yeah with footage
contributed by Jake and Max I want to
say like no 30 seconds of my flight he's
like what are some your good shots only
here you go I think 5 seconds of my
curse our mode ended up in there as well
yeah yeah so read that know what I've
got I don't know what I have next
maybe I'll go play blitz and yeah I'll
play you blitz we are gonna have stuff
on blitz up on the site pretty soon so
if you're listening to this on Friday
the day it goes up then please look out
for that's the goal anyway is to have
some ooh blitz stuff up for for your
enjoyment cool and you can find me at
Jacob deck and right now we're working
on a cyberpunk video about the history
of my city another one we're gonna keep
going we're not gonna stop history
history of night city and then apart
from that I also with the help of
jean-luc max J and two more put together
a montage of some of the best photo mode
animated images we got I guess that's my
animated image doesn't make sense
animated shots we got and that should be
up by now so make sure to check that out
because some of those photos are like
incredible there's one in particular
that you added in like I think it wasn't
in the original it wasn't I just need a
second one I liked as I was taking it I
was like I can't believe I took a photo
that looks this good I can legitimately
thought it was like concept art I was
like this chick just pulled that from
the internet that's not real and I was
like oh my god that game looks good
anyway we'll see you all next week
[Music]